>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
HOUSTON, TEXAS, IS ONE OF THE
RARE NICE BIG CITIES LEFT IN HIS
COUNTRY.
A LITTLE HOT IN THE SUMMER, BUT
GREAT PEOPLE, VERY PRETTY
NEIGHBORHOODS AND A LOT GOING
ON.
THANKS TO THE ENERGY SECTOR,
BIOTECH AND AEROSPACE, HOUSTON
HAS AN ENORMOUS AND STILL ROBUST
ECONOMY.
IT IS HARDLY SOME DYING MILLTOWN
IN THE NORTHEAST OR THE UPPER
MIDWEST.
YOUR KIDS MIGHT WANT TO MOVE TO
HOUSTON SOMEDAY, MAYBE AFTER
COLLEGE.
IT'S NOT BALTIMORE.
BUT ALL OF A SUDDEN HOUSTON,
TEXAS, IS STARTING TO LOOK A
LITTLE BIT MORE LIKE BALTIMORE.
CRIME IN HOUSTON HAS GOTTEN
SCARY.
THE MURDER RATE THERE HAS RISEN
BY MORE THAN 50% IN JUST THE
LAST YEAR.
IT'S BAD.
HERE'S A LOCAL NEWS REPORT.
>> A DEADLY START TO THE YEAR
ACROSS HOUSTON.
POLICE INVESTIGATING AT LEAST 41
HOMICIDES THROUGH 24 DAYS.
SO FAR THIS YEAR, HOUSTON HAS
MORE MURDERS THAN NEW YORK CITY,
LOS ANGELES, EVEN CHICAGO.
>> IT'S ONE OF THOSE THINGS
WHERE I'M FEARFUL FOR MY FAMILY
JUST TO GO OUT OF THE HOUSE.
>> THE PRESIDENT OF THE HOUSTON
POLICE OFFICERS UNION
FRUSTRATED.
>> IF IT KEEPS UP THE SPACE WE
WILL BE WELL OVER 500 MURDERS
THIS YEAR.
>> Tucker: I'M FEARFUL JUST
FOR MY FAMILY TO GO OUTSIDE OF
THE HOUSE.
AS YOU HEARD, THAT WAS THE
PRESIDENT OF THE POLICE UNION IN
HOUSTON, SO HE WOULD KNOW.
IT'S AMAZING THIS IS HAPPENING
IN ALL PLACES IN HOUSTON AND
WHAT'S SO TELLING ABOUT THIS
CRIME WAVE IS HOW RECENTLY IT
BEGAN.
MURDERS IN HOUSTON START TO
SPIKE IN A BIG WAY AFTER
JOE BIDEN BECAME PRESIDENT.
WHY IS THAT EXACTLY?
VERY SIMPLE ANSWER.
JOE BIDEN OPENED THE SOUTHERN
BORDER.
TEXAS SHARES MORE THAN
1200 MILES OF BORDER WITH
MEXICO.
THERE'S A BRUTAL CARTEL WAR
UNDERWAY IN MEXICO RIGHT NOW.
IT'S BEEN GOING ON FOR A LONG
TIME.
MANY OF THE COMBATANTS IN THAT
WAR HAVE NOW MOVED NORTH INTO
TEXAS.
THEY BROUGHT DRUGS WITH THEM.
THEY'VE ALSO BROUGHT MACHINE
GUNS.
THIS FALL, FELL IN OPEN FIRE ON
HOUSTON POLICE OFFICERS WITH A
FULLY AUTOMATIC RIFLE.
YOU HEAR A LOT ABOUT ASSAULT
WEAPONS, BUT THE TRUTH IS
AUTHORITIES DON'T SEE FULLY
AUTOMATIC WEAPONS AREA OFTEN.
THEY ARE HEAVILY REGULATED AND
TYPICALLY THEY ARE OWNED BY
COLLECTORS.
BUT AUTOMATIC WEAPONS ARE VERY
COMMON IN WAR ZONES, AND THERE
IS A WAR IN MEXICO.
SO WITH NO BORDER IN PLACE, THE
CARTELS ARE BRINGING THEIR
ARMAMENTS HERE.
WATCH THIS FIREFIGHT IN HOUSTON.
>> IT'S HOUSTON POLICE.
[BLEEP].
[GUNFIRE]
>> IT'S THE POLICE.
>> Tucker: THAT'S AUTOMATIC
WEAPONS FIRE.
IT SOUNDS LIKE SYRIA OR MEXICO.
BUT IT'S AN APARTMENT COMPLEX IN
HOUSTON, TEXAS.
WE CAN GO ON.
IF YOU KNOW ANY BUDDY WHO LIVES
IN HOUSTON, CALL AND ASK HOW IS
YOUR CITY CHANGED RECENTLY, AND
THEY WILL TELL YOU.
OPEN BORDERS DID THIS.
HOUSTON DIDN'T DO IT TO ITSELF.
THIS WAS DONE TO HOUSTON.
I'M NOT JUST TO HOUSTON, TO SO
MANY PLACES ACROSS THIS COUNTRY
WERE MILLIONS OF ILLEGAL ALIENS
HAVE FLOODED IN DURING
JOE BIDEN'S PRESIDENCY.
ON MONDAY, FOR EXAMPLE, MORE
THAN 100 ILLEGAL HAITIAN
MIGRANTS LANDED IN THE
FLORIDA KEYS IN A SINGLE BOAT.
YOU'RE WATCHING AERIAL FOOTAGE
SUMMERLIN KEY FLORIDA.
PICTURES LIKE THIS ARE NO LONGER
UNCOMMON IN THE STATE OF
FLORIDA.
THE WORLD IS COMING TO AMERICA'S
SHORES.
WHY?
BECAUSE THEY ARE FULLY AWARE
THAT THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
REWARDING FOR NATIONALS FOR
VIOLATING OUR FEDERAL
IMMIGRATION LAW.
IT IS AN INVASION.
HUGE NUMBER'S OF AMERICANS ARE
DYING AS A RESULT OF THAT
INVASION.
100,000 DEAD LAST YEAR OF DRUG
ODs, MOST WERE KILLED BY
FENTANYL.
THAT IS TRUCKED IN FROM MEXICO
ACROSS OPEN BORDERS.
LONG-TERM, THERE ARE MASSIVE
LABOR MARKET DESTRUCTIONS.
THERE IS EVAPORATING SOCIAL
COHESION AND SO ON.
THE COSTS OF THIS HAVE BEEN
BEYOND CALCULATING.
AND THIS IS EXACTLY WHY NO SANE
COUNTRY OPENS ITS BORDERS EVER.
EVER.
ANYWHERE.
WHAT JOE BIDEN IS DOING RIGHT
NOW HAS NEVER BEEN DONE.
AND IT'S ABOUT TO GET MUCH
WORSE.
WE ARE NOT GUESSING.
CURRENTLY A TRUMP ERA REGULATION
CALLED TITLE 42 ALLOWS THE
BORDER PATROL TO TURN ILLEGAL
MIGRANTS BACK TO MEXICO ON THE
GROUNDS THAT THERE'S A PANDEMIC
IN PROGRESS SO WE PROBABLY
SHOULDN'T LET MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
INFECTED WITH COVID MOVE HERE
WITHOUT PERMISSION.
SEEMS SENSIBLE.
BUT ACCORDING TO DEMOCRATS, THIS
RULE IS RACIST BECAUSE IT MIGHT
SLOW THE HUMAN WAVE OF
MIGRATION, SO FOR MONTHS THEY'VE
BEEN DEMANDING THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION SUSPEND THIS
WORLD.
WATCH THEM.
>> I URGE PRESIDENT BIDEN AND
SECRETARY MAYORKAS TO
IMMEDIATELY PUT A STOP TO THESE
EXPULSIONS AND TO END THIS TITLE
42 POLICY AT OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER.
WE CANNOT CONTINUE THESE HATEFUL
AND XENOPHOBIC TRUMP POLICIES.
>> IN ADDITION, A RELIC TITLE
42, EXISTS.
IT IS A RELIC OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
IT WAS CREATED TO BE
MEAN-SPIRITED.
TITLE 42, I ASK FOR A SUSPENSION
OF IT.
>> I URGE THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION AND MY COLLEAGUES
TO REMEMBER THE REFUGEES WHO ARE
WAITING AT OUR BORDER KEPT UP BY
THE CRUEL AND UNNECESSARY TITLE
42 POLICY.
>> TITLE 42 IS BEING USED IN A
WAY THAT I THINK IS
INDISCRIMINATE AND THAT VIOLATES
THE BASIC ESSENCE OF OUR LAW.
BUT THIS PROCESS THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS CONTINUED
FROM THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IN
MY MIND IS INEXCUSABLE.
>> Tucker: SO YOUR KID HAS TO
WEAR A MASK IN SCHOOL, BUT
ILLEGAL ALIENS GET TO COME HERE
WITH NO RESTRICTIONS AT ALL
DESPITE THE FACT THEY MAY BE
INFECTED WITH COVID, BECAUSE
OTHERWISE YOU'RE A RACIST.
THAT'S THE CASE THEY WERE MAKING
AND SO FINALLY, INEVITABLY, THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS CAVED.
IT TURNS OUT EVEN TRYING TO
MAINTAIN BASIC PUBLIC HEALTH
STANDARDS IS ON ACCEPTABLE IF IT
GETS IN THE WAY OF INCREASING
MASS IMMIGRATION.
TITLE 42 HAS BEEN NULLIFIED.
A SIMILAR RULE THAT YOU KNOW
SHOULD STILL APPLY TO YOU,
AMERICAN CITIZENS, NOT EXEMPT.
TO THIS DAY, U.S. A U.S. CITIZEN
ARE NOT ALLOWED TO RETURN TO THE
UNIT STATES WITHOUT PERMISSION
FROM THE CDC.
ROCHELLE WALENSKY WILL SIGN OFF
ON THAT.
COMING BACK TO THE COUNTRY YOU
WERE BORN AND IS NO LONGER YOUR
BIRTHRIGHT BUT ILLEGAL ALIENS
NOW FACE NO LEGAL BARRIERS AT
ALL.
AND OF COURSE THEY KNOW IT.
EVERYONE KNOWS IT.
IT'S NOT THEIR FAULT, IT'S OUR
PRESIDENT'S FAULT.
ACCORDING TO AXIOS, "U.S.
INTELLIGENCE OFFICIALS ARE
QUIETLY BRACING FOR A MASSIVE
INFLUX OF MORE THAN 170,000
MIGRANTS AT THE MEXICO BORDER
NOW THAT TITLE 42 IS ENDING."
SO THE WAY IT GROWS, THE TOTAL
TRANSFORMATION OF THIS COUNTRY
ACCELERATES.
WE'VE BEEN VERY PASSIVE IN THE
FACE OF THIS, PEOPLE MAKE GRUMPY
NOISES ABOUT IT.
NOBODY HAS DONE ANYTHING.
HOW SHOULD WE RESPOND?
THE SAME WAY WE RESPOND TO ANY
OTHER INVASION, WITH THE U.S.
MILITARY.
THAT'S WHY COUNTRIES HAVE
MILITARIES, TO STOP INVASIONS,
AND THIS WOULD NOT BE A HARD
INVASION TO STOP.
OUR MILITARY COULD SEAL THE
BORDER WITH MEXICO IN DAYS.
THAT WOULD SAVE AMERICAN LIVES,
IT WOULD RESTORE ORDER AND IT
WOULD END THE INVASION.
DOES THAT SOUND CRAZY?
LIKE A MISUSE OF THE U.S.
MILITARY?
KEEP IN MIND THAT NANCY PELOSI
CALLED IN THE U.S. MILITARY TO
PROTECT HER FROM TRUMP VOTERS AT
THE U.S. CAPITOL.
SHE TREATED OUR SOLDIERS LIKE
HER PERSONAL SECURITY DETAIL.
AND THEN OF COURSE AT THIS VERY
MOMENT WE ARE SENDING THOUSANDS
OF AMERICAN TROOPS AND BILLIONS
IN AMERICAN MILITARY HARDWARE TO
EASTERN EUROPE TO HELP THE
UKRAINIANS RESTORE THEIR
BORDERS.
SO THE OBVIOUS QUESTION IS, WHY
NOT HERE?
WHY NOT TAKE AMERICA'S SAFETY,
YOUR FAMILY'S SAFETY, AS SERIOUS
AS NANCY PELOSI TAKES HER OWN
SAFETY?
THAT SEEMS LIKE A FAIR QUESTION.
PROBABLY NOT RUSSIAN
INFORMATION, PROBABLY AN HONEST
QUESTION.
WE SPOKE TO CONGRESSMAN MARIA
SALAZAR YESTERDAY AND WE ASK
THAT QUESTION OF HER, SHE
REFUSED TO ANSWER.
WATCH HOW SHE REFUSED.
>> I JUST CAN'T HELP NOTICE THE
CONTRAST BETWEEN YOUR DESIRE TO
SEND MIGS TO UKRAINE TO PRESERVE
ITS BORDERS BUT NOT HERE.
SHOULD WE SEND THE U.S. MILITARY
TO THE MEXICAN BORDER SINCE YOU
HAVE ADMITTED THAT TENS OF
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE HAVE COME
HERE ILLEGALLY?
THAT OUR BORDERS ARE POROUS,
THEY ARE NOT DEFENDED, THEY ARE
OPEN.
SHOULD WE SEND THE U.S. MILITARY
TO THE MEXICAN BORDER?
>> THAT IS WHAT I HAVE CREATED A
WHOLE PLAN SO WE CAN REALLY SEAL
THE BORDER, BECAUSE YOU KNOW
WHAT?
MIGHT --
LET ME FINISH.
>> Tucker: YOU REPRESENT
AMERICA.
I'M ASKING A QUESTION ABOUT
BORDERS.
ALL OF US ARE APPALLED FOR THE
VIOLATION UKRAINE'S BORDERS.
YOU DON'T SEEM AS APPALLED BY A
VIOLATION OF OUR BORDERS, BY
TENS OF MILLIONS OF PEOPLE, SO
LET ME ASK YOU FOR THE THIRD
TIME.
>> SURE I DO.
THAT'S A MISS OUR PRESENT
TATIAN.
>> Tucker: OKAY THEN WOULD YOU
SUPPORT THE U.S. MILITARY
SECURING THE UNITED STATES
BORDER TONIGHT OR ON THE SAME
TIMETABLE AS SENDING MIGS TO
UKRAINE?
HOW ABOUT THAT?
>> THAT'S HYPOTHETICAL AGAIN.
>> Tucker: OH, IT'S
HYPOTHETICAL.
I'VE GOT A PLAN!
RIGHT.
HOW MANY PLANS IF YOU HEARD
ABOUT FROM REPUBLICANS FOR SAY
THE PAST 25 YEARS?
MANY, MANY, MANY.
TO RESTATE, THIS IS A HIGHLY
DANGEROUS SITUATION THAT THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS PLACED
OUR COUNTRY IN.
MEXICO, WHATEVER ITS MERITS, IS
IN THE MIDDLE OF A WAR.
NOT A NEW WAR, A WAR THAT HAS
RAGED ON FOR MORE THAN A DECADE
OUT, AWARE THAT HAS LIKELY
KILLED MORE THAN 100,000 PEOPLE
SO FAR.
MISSING FOOTAGE ON YOUR SCREEN
RIGHT NOW OF TRUCKS BURNING.
THAT'S JUST FEED FROM THE U.S.
BORDER -- FEET FROM THE U.S.
BORDER IN THE STATE OF TEXAS.
WHAT YOU'RE LOOKING AT IS AN
AFTERMATH OF A THREE HOUR GUN
BATTLE BETWEEN CARTELS
GOVERNMENT FORCES.
YOU'LL NOTICE THE SITUATION
THERE IS SO CHAOTIC THAT THE
TRUCKS JUST BURN IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE ROAD.
NO ONE COMES TO PUT UP THE FIRES
TO PUT UP ORDERS TO ARREST
ANYONE.
THAT'S NOT A LAW ENFORCEMENT
ACTION, THAT'S A WAR.
THAT'S WHAT WARS ARE LIKE.
A FEW YEARS AGO THEY USED HEAVY
MACHINE GUNS AND ARMORED
VEHICLES TO WIN THE PITCHED
BATTLE AGAINST THE MEXICAN
MILITARY.
THAT'S A WAR, CIVIL WAR FEET
FROM OUR BORDER.
THAT'S THE COUNTRY JOE BIDEN
OPENED OUR BORDER TOO.
IT'S INSANITY.
AND YET SOMEHOW OUR CONGRESS
CANNOT BE BOTHERED TO NOTICE
THIS, ANY OF IT.
EVEN AS MILLIONS STREAM ACROSS.
MURDER VICTIMS IN HOUSTON A
PARENT I DON'T HAVE INFLUENTIAL
SOCIAL MEDIA ACCOUNTS SO KEVIN
McCARTHY DOESN'T KNOW THAT
THEY EXIST AND THAT'S A SHAME
BECAUSE WHEN HE SEES IT ON
TIKTOK, HE ACTS.
HERE'S McCARTHY DEMANDING WE
SEND MILITARY EQUIPMENT ACROSS
THE WORLD TO STOP THE INVASION
OF ANOTHER COUNTRY.
WATCH.
>> WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT WHAT
PRESIDENT BIDEN SHOULD DO, I
THINK THERE'S A BIPARTISAN
MOVEMENT RIGHT HERE, PROVIDE
THEM THE MIGS.
PROVIDE THEM THE PLANES WHERE
THEY CAN CREATE A NO-FLY ZONE.
PROVIDE THEM THE ARMAMENT THAT
THEY NEED TO CONTINUE TO FIGHT A
WAR THAT THEY DID NOT CREATE.
>> Tucker: SO McCARTHY SAYS
THE UKRAINIANS, IT'S A WAR THEY
DIDN'T CREATE AND THAT IS
CERTAINLY TRUE.
BUT UKRAINIANS DID NOT CREATE
THAT WAR, THEY DID NOT INVADE
THEIR OWN COUNTRY.
BUT WE DIDN'T EITHER.
WE DIDN'T INVADE OUR OWN
COUNTRY.
VERY FEW AMERICANS WANTED TO
OPEN OUR BORDER TO A NARCO STATE
IN THE MIDDLE OF A DRUG WAR.
JOE BIDEN DID THAT TO US.
AND NO ONE CARES.
SO MAYBE WE NEED OUR OWN
ZELE